this week's videos are sponsored by
manscape more on them after the reaction
people Alon ladies and gentlemen we are
here for the Doctor Who 60th anniversary
Johnny my companion mate how are you I I
am tyy WHYY G how are you I am so
excited I've thought about nothing but
Doctor Who yesterday it's kind of crazy
because we started watching this at our
patreon with uh in modern who we have
been watching it every single week for a
couple of years and then we had a our
first period where oh now there're
several months without Doctor Who we're
caught up what do we do and it was the
first time we've ever had a chance to
miss Doctor Who since we started as I
was like getting some Refreshers I was
like man I really I just couldn't stop
thinking about I'm like I got like
jacked up about butterlies like tenant's
coming back like all sorts of things
could happen Donna like what are we
going to do I haven't been this excited
for Doctor Who Um ever just because this
is the first time we had an opportunity
to miss it ladies and Gentlemen please
go ahead use that Sonic Screwdriver to
leave a like on this video that'd be
very much appreciated also subscribe
click the notification Bell cuz
apparently John there's three specials
didn't know that oh yes it's and then
there's a Christmas special after that
this video is going to be edited by our
friend Eric he might know him as nerd
cic he actually helps run the website
passion fruit which goes to heavily
support reactors I've done an interview
there myself you guys should go ahead
check it out and as always full length
retion watch along just PR snle with
your own copy of Doctor Who that is
available for our super sexy rejects
over at our patreon page and we cover
several shows exclusively over there
with highlights and watch along secluded
including all of the Doctor Who that we
did but this being the first part of the
special and the first time we ever
putting this on YouTube with Doctor Who
the watch along for this one will be
made public for everyone so go ahead you
can check it out Link in the description
box any who John you excited I'm very
excited let's see what
happens once upon a time once upon a
time
lord sometimes I have dreams about
impossible things
oh yeah do you dream of impossible
children by taking the power of the time
Lords into her mind at a terrible cost
binary binary binary binary I totally
think she's going to die John a man
they're going to switch her out so that
she becomes the 15th doctor but now this
face has come back so are my mannerisms
yes everything about me I think the
story hasn't ended yet
nope whoa
oo nipple
chills
[Music]
damn damn the retro
logo and a reorchestration of the theme
music new theme credits sequence oh my
God what if this
sucks look at that stride and his hair
is always so perfectly sculpted
oh hold on hold on
Z
ah
[Music]
fate
Rose whoa Rose her daughter I know but
through David tenant's eyes whoa oh yeah
sorry he's not St this right
my I said never trust damn these effects
look great it's a spaceship in trouble
mom look it's a spaceship
yes right now it's like she's
greats
W there you go you really didn't pay
attention to any of that Donna is she
like cosmically repelled from seeing
these things word of advice you can wear
a suit that tight up to the age of
[Music]
35 Rose the hubby hey oh grandm of the
knowledge your
mistress catcher catcher
catch she's done a temple now she
refused to be Noble Temple cuz she says
it sounds like an old
r that sounds like Donna didn't you win
the lottery supposed to be a secret oh
yeah to charity every single penny well
we bought the house something we did do
I would have divorced wow she knew that
oh next left
I want a GPS voice that's the doctor
this already does really have that
wonder and spirit that I had been
missing from Doc who while still feeling
quite modern and we liked Whitaker we
did all right we did and I should know I
invented them mom mom Gran did you see
that spaceship no I didn't and I won't
and I couldn't Adit how many more times
there no such thing as spaceships oh
does she avoid for Donna yeah
I would burn down the world for you
darling anyone has a go I will be there
and I will descend I Miss Donna so much
that reminds me of the doctor saying how
he was burning down the Sun for Rose is
that an did I catch an Easter Easter egg
cuz she's Rose she I
do when is it sexist never said it to
him when he
was no sorry does she look gorgeous yeah
I just get so clumsy I know
so do I the relationship seems like it's
gotten a little better flying sources
did I tell you I saw Susie May she's
looking a lot better now the negligence
in the conversation has more meaning
sometimes I think there's something
missing nope not possible like I had
something lovely like something should
be there but it's not and winning the
lottery you could have avoided all his
thoughts he just have a stack of money
look over at what have I lost
oh I don't like to see Donna
Wayward this is straight up feel like ET
now yeah it totally is or Gremlins
even oh meep meep that definitely is
some Gremlins what are you I am the Meep
you can talk the MEEP the Meep I fell
from the stars I hurt my
PO it's a lovely animatronic is an
animatronic looks like a I must have
done some hybrid splice with CGI right
unless I'm just being real fooled whoa
damn leave him continue the
hunt bug
dudes whoa
cool got a side gig as a light painter
evening do shery I'm Bingham unit
Scientific Advisor number 56 new
character excellent I don't know who I
am anymore that's not new want in a
skinny suit after that I wear a bow tie
after that I'm a Scotsman after that I'm
a woman you got your old face back yep
you are the future that's what I'm
worried about maybe the unfinished
business with Donna I absolutely love
her oh do I say things like that now
it's got that femininity sensitive side
yeah I get this face back in the Tet
lands right next to her I turn around
there's a husband then a spaceship
crashes right in front of her it's like
she's drawing Us in it's like the first
time I don't believe in destiny but if
Destiny exists then it is heading for
Donna Noble right now
Russell T Davies loves to deal with
Destiny Russell te
Destiny okay let's see if this key pulse
works at
Arms I'm doing my
[Music]
part a third creature
whoa oh oh oh no that's that's no bueno
it's like enchanting oh it's an extra
dimensional
Force I wear my
[Music]
sunglass me me okay oh hello so you me
this is Super E I made some little
friends oh giant googly ey they're just
toys why won't you speak to the little
me be my friend be my friend I keep
hovering between creeped out and
endeared
yes these are toys humans have toys
they've got stuffing
inside everything is literal in Meep
world is the same old thing and who ends
up doing the bin Mom it says keep out
this kind of like a funny amalgamation
of like having Donna and Rose and Rose
with how she had her mom Rose Tyler yeah
exactly oh that is your best year no I
know but that woman from Abu Dhabi who
buys your stuff she'd love that one you
could charge her really a straight up
teacher of yeah 100% oh my God those
eyes are amazing oh no poke it poke
it what what this is when donno dies
yes what the
hell don't look at me look away right
now it isn't
real let me
in you this is so funny how the mom was
such a neglectful personality and now it
that just translates she's now she's
actually protecting her she's fiercely
protective no such thing as spaceships
we've got a bloody Martian in the
sh classic
[Music]
Donna I'm not going anywhere we could
sell mad Paddington for a million
qu the
fridge there was one person missing I
used to know your granddad wolf he's not
with us anymore he wasn't
young I love that man he was the best he
was the best I'm so sorry for your lost
he's not dead you idiot he's in
sheltered accommodation he's 94 he can't
manage the stairs W live
alive run by that lot in the middle of
town unit this woman in charge coach she
says an old Soldier she'll look after
him
okay me me yes the Meep I promise I can
help him get home and then you'll never
see me again you're assuming he as a
pronoun um true yes sorry good point are
You My Chosen pronoun is the definite
article I am always the me oh I do that
I do that the WTH Warriors they
cultivate meat kind for our beautiful
fur you're a fashion
vict nicely put it breaks both my heart
two hearts like you two hearts so do I
you've got what four hearts that beat as
one we demand to search the house this
has been declared in military zone sorry
say that again we demand to search the
house this has been declared a military
zone he so good tenant just slips back
into this role I didn't even realize
magical he's just made for
it
wa
cool
that's cool that's some like Mission
Impossible right there wow this
thing can like really they've taken
Sonic every year they do something there
yep yep
yep just keep on firing they can still
shoot at the staircase is a sonic
screwdriver why are you telling her one
thing it's resonating
concrete
ooh hidden
roomes
down that was an excellent shot
yeah God drone
shot this is a bigger than usual like
action scene I know like is this a real
neighborhood or is this like just using
the whole back lot
today I want a doctor who car chase
where he's driving just r old regular
car Red
Dawn good call
yeah
H couldn't have thrown a blanket over it
coat yeah or something a hat damn this
car can take bols or alien lasers laser
blasts either we
escaped but we've got things very very
wrong a little bit of both
yeah what is the Meep
hiding solid transition it's interesting
the jua position of very much improved
like budget and cinematography and just
overall scale and then you have these
like bug creatures that feel extremely
retro totally like guys in
rub
yeah kind of in the middle this PT is
now in session where'd he get that I'm
invoking Shadow Proclamation protocols
15 P.M and six Shadow Proclamation
exhibit a the tax no Scorch marks Donna
can you confirm um okay that's
intentional yeah those guns are stun
guns if I may speak address the court
the story of the meat is a tragic tale
one terrible day the sun went mad the
Marvels solar cycadia it renders them as
Mania the Meep Army captured the
galactic C beheaded them and ate them
wow the most cruel and Despicable of all
weep Meep there one what are you
saying to hell with this oh damn
whoa
dude die I knew it was creepy yeah I
don't need to pretend for I am the beep
of all the
meeps bar
what a fun flip on what you normally
expect out of this show so stupid no no
you're not we could be living somewhere
far away from here gave away that
Lottery money why because there are
places out there where people are in
danger the doctor's in her doct da whole
time I was like that's your way of
helping can't travel across space thing
a to he w w would do that also yeah a
great day for meep
and the start of a new reign of terror
activate the initializers initializers
love how its entire eyes have changed
yeah Donna is the only one in a shade of
red everyone else is in shades of blue
even Shadow hey hey nice got weapons in
your wheelchair we all have we all have
everybody with a wheelchair has weapons
DAV us
Origins I don't just fire dce
mate wowe a little goofy but I like it
become like a 70s James Bond movie yeah
exactly what's the most inventive Gadget
we can come up with we got to make it
just got to find out no you can't take
her I love you Sean but if the doctor
can't save the city we're all going to
die I've got
help doctor she called him doctor yeah
she did oh I didn't catch that she
said doctor and I was like oh that's the
first time
right
run that's so funny tenant is the most
associated with
running oh
no come on Indy grab your hat switches
the top ones the blue ones sck them all
down I mean maybe she's dagger drive
it's been growing in her for a while
maybe her body's
maybe it is yeah maybe it's like slowly
habituated coincidence who's heading
here save London from burning but it
will kill you
oh okay you'll die my daughter is down
there it's 9 million people you guess
about me I do
a why does it have to be this
entering final SE uh jeez where are we
go Pelican oh these must be the words to
awaken I don't care what it is unlock
the Safeguard he's Awakening the Winter
Soldier
grief
fingerprint ceration
oh binary
binary
binary binary
fin
whoa are you all
right I gave away my
money right I gave
away all my money and do you know why I
had a subconscious INF cutaneous
retroold memory
[Music]
loop6 6 million pound yes Donna
destruction of London oh I'll show you
destruction M
yes vindicate the Cyber line and roast
the
hyper like this theost
dri I mean she seems fine there will be
consequences but their Rhythm together
is exquisite best5 seconds of my life
really just 55 seconds no no we did it
she's fine you saved
her you saved them all what is this
going to happen to say
goodbye good
fun no
what in this episode I thought it would
be like I know it you were
beaten by the Dr Donna Dr Donna said it
yes oh oh but how closing down all
psychedelic light wave amators and
transferring Rose is the key too much
power for one person but you had a
chance transfer PR has passed down I
shared inheritance wow nonbinary non
wa wa that is working on multiple levels
damn oh the was our memory of
course did look like the to
First Every Creature we met she
remembered as a
toy a Cyberman oh is that adapost
oh my
God yeah the oud were the called her the
Dr Donna too
yeah and neither yes and more a
nonbinary gender Dave is working with
it
woke we had a whole couple seasons of
Jody Whitaker we're way past woke
comparison oh I will escape and have my
venge just wait till I tell the boss
Thanos we've still got to fix you two
yes we know we know everything thanks
and you know nothing time you're not a
woman anymore could she' have understood
kind of want to see the mean something a
male presenting Time Lord will never
understand and we choose to let it
go
whoa wower finally me
[Music]
damn time Lord's unlocked well I was
thinking we could go see will now that
is cheap just a suggestion I mean it
don't you dare did the actor pass away
yes in 2022 so I'm thinking like did
they shoot some kind of secret footage
or are they just teasing us it's like
the old days just me and the doctor
together is that all right yeah
this you you just don't ever give a
to
[Music]
you
him whoa he hasn't even seen this
has wow wow we it's the Men in Black
headquarters this is
amaz hit is wow it is so bright is this
the first time we've seen the doctor
excited over the inside of a TARDIS
in this fashion
perhaps and the swell of
strings wow what a fun set it's got this
it's got this and
that that is beautiful wow UV lights
it's like a infrared sauna oh come
on it's
[Music]
gorgeous this like a
makeover what about your face why did it
come back I'm stuck with it now for at
least three
episodes thank you very much careful how
I lost my job drop coffee in the
computer here we are having a coffee
what's going to go
wrong wowe of course
no oh Jesus this is a really got it out
of control oh my
God no something always happens you said
it
yourself no IDE completely out of
control yeah and then some Jesus I've
never seen the Tardis console so angry
over one coffee spill it's it no way
water
resistant
oh wa is like chanting breaths wow wow
wow wow wow well you know man now that
the doctor is back to being a man yes
got some grooming to take care of you
know oh I think he does all that running
around you might cha and if he can
travel to the year 2023 he can just get
a
exceptional transition Mary balsas
reject Nation you know what the funny
thing is I already own this product
before agreeing to do this partnership I
could have used my influencer ring to
get it for free or at a discount but hey
now you can get it at a discount cuz
this week we are of course sponsored by
manscaped as a married man who's always
on the move I value looking sharp all
keeping things efficient that's
ranscapes performance package 5.0 Ultra
comes in featuring the lawn mower 5.0
and it is a game changer the package is
honestly a perfect gift for yourself or
for another man that you might know I'll
give this to John if anyone ask I pay
for it out of my own pocket but no
seriously this is easily the best
because it comes with not one but two
NextGen blade heads see the difference
it's good thing I have two now for
demonstration purposes you got the
standard trimmer for a perfect neat trim
but this one the new foil blade for that
super smooth finish and oh yeah it's all
about safe grooming with their Advanced
Skin safe technology plus they're
waterproof so no more crumbs on the
carpet the package also includes a weed
whacker 2.0 for ear and nose and I
definitely use this because look at me
I'm a hairy guy and the must have liquid
formations the crop Soother After Shave
lotion and the crop preserver ball
deodorant say goodbye to posave of
irritation and hello freshness and the
ultimate cherry on top two free GI GI
manscapes premium boxers 2.0 and the
2.0 toiletry bag again I already
have one the boxers I'm wearing my pair
right now and the bag is perfect for all
your grooming Essentials as you can see
so you ready to elevate your grooming
game head to manscape.com and use code
rejects for a cool 20% off plus free
shipping remember it's rejects for 20%
off at manscape.com let's get those
jingle balls holiday ready with
manscaped boy oh boy good to have Doctor
Who back so the Meep is a trans fob yes
among other things I guess yeah you know
not not very tolerant that Meep even
though have its own personal pronoun
preference now listen I am a full
supporter of trans rights in every way
um but at the same time I cannot
possibly at one part of me truly
understand what it's like to be a trans
person sure and sometimes there's some
messaging that happens where I'm like
I'm always for but I might ask a couple
of questions here or there yeah just so
I can better understand when there's an
allegory you know relevant to life but
also mixed up in sci-fi circumstances
you know you got to kind of interpret
yeah yeah man as a matter of fact at our
patreon uh the one who's every say our
patreon what we always do is read these
like facts from from each episode of
Doctor Who uh our most staunch Patron or
super you call super sexy reject um is
transgender and we we get excited now to
see this amount of trans for an allegory
because accept yeah it's so cool it's
not even just allegory it's actually
quite direct you know yeah it's true
representation I I think that's there
I'm sure there's parts of any Community
or fandom that's like what the hell
however I think with Doctor Who uh I
feel like it's probably something that's
being very much embraced right now I
have which I think is excellent I feel
like doctor who comes with a spirit of
inclusivity I feel like it's probably a
little ironic to be winging about you
know things like that on a show like
this yeah and I mean I can just imagine
just like the the trans audience for
Doctor Who and the queer audience for Dr
Who like they have to be so very vast
and I can only imagine the joy and
probably the kind of overflowing of
emotion that that you know people are
probably having with this yeah I mean we
had jod Whitaker which uh as expected
got like I mean we we already were like
aware that doctor who would eventually
become Jody
Whitaker when we were starting up the
show I think you think we're already at
that point well into her run yeah yeah
so we were so we were like yeah we were
aware um didn't really care but we were
aware that there was a bunch of negative
talk about it so I feel like we're at a
point where we could be past that
hopefully we'll see I matters I feel
like things move in in in like slow
tandems where it's like okay people
wrapped their mind around the doctor
being a woman and that's one thing to
wrap your mind around and now there's
you know a more overt sort of trans
allegory or whatever it might be and
that's another thing to kind of level
one step up and wrap your mind further
around the reason I'm bringing bringing
up Jody Whitaker sure is because the
backlash
to changing the doctor from a man for so
many years to then having a a tenure
with a with a with an
actress then to bring back
tenet I think there's something really
admirable in Russell T Davies going hey
this ain't us reverting back we're gonna
we're gonna we're going to double down
on some right now this is us making
up for woman doctor by bringing back
your favorite man doctor and then we're
going to really Embrace trans rights
yeah yeah yeah and I mean and and to do
it you know I think it's it's also uh
smart to go back to Dr Donna you know go
back to a character who wasn't always
you know doctored but certainly is now
or at least for the moment is well yeah
I think it's quite admirable it's pretty
cool to me that it's nothing along the
lines of what some some Camp may have
been like maybe they're going to try to
rewrite it because the jod whiter era
like we there were some some of those
episodes like we love the flux Arc and
there's so much about um jod Whitaker's
performance itself that was just so
excellent and but we were there to
experience some like really awful
writing periods of Doctor Who where I
was like okay I see what people are
talking about some of this is really not
it was the unfortunate thing of like jod
Whitaker is great and this is a fine
idea but also like the writing of this
could could be better could be some of
the tonality could be more rich or
unified or whatever it is and then they
made some bold choices with changing up
the lore with the Timeless child and all
these things everyone loves the Timeless
child then to go back to tenet you know
it I did hear some of the conversation
of oh is he going to try to like course
correct is he going to try to rewrite
some things and that's why I'm I wanted
to start off immediately with where the
show was ending off with of hey it's
neat that Russell T Davies actually
decided to really embrace it yeah
find an extension of it and like wear it
on its sleeve it doesn't they don't shy
away at all no and in a way that I think
yeah is like it it's very like heartfelt
in that way and you could tell the show
really cares about doing that just as
much as it cares about everything El
like this was a lovely re-entry and I
think there's always like some level of
State like it's kind of funky uh
stepping into the shoes of
everybody else who's a hoo and where now
you get to anticipate and it's like you
know some specials are better than
others usually the
anniversaries are are pretty you know
momentous or whatever um but yeah this
managed to bring us back in in a way
that was you know reaching for you know
some kind of relevant you know uh uh
meaning applicable to our place and time
but also not losing sight of any of the
history between the doctor and Donna not
losing sight of any of the fun and
tradition of Doctor Who not losing sight
of homaging you know various Sci-Fi
movies that came before like they really
kind of seemed to put everything into
all of the elements and so I feel like
it earns the allegory and it earns
everything else by doing so and I think
it's you know it's I I'm curious to hear
more commentary and more you know kind
of breakdowns of some of those more yeah
pertinent uh uh moments in terms of the
allegory just yeah just to kind of see
how people feel about the articulation
and how it intermingles with the you
know more sci-fi elements of like
literally letting the energy go you know
and and fixing the meta crisis and all
that stuff well I like it because it
does it with a big smile on its face and
an eye for the characters first and
foremost the the way how yes that that
it's the way how I felt about how like
the messaging and Barbie doesn't bother
me because it does it with a big smile
on its face yeah and it's like part of
the point is we're going to talk about
this yeah this is the Sterling example
of something that's been like gendered
and and used to instruct since its
Inception and now we're going to
deconstruct that yeah they're going to
they lead with that and so I I
appreciated it yeah um the the part of
it though that I am a little back and
forth on and my initial feeling on it is
only because of the amount
of tension and
suspense and built in of the whole
letting go of the residual galif Fray
DNA yeah the like regenerative time
regenerative energy yeah that uh resided
within Donna like I like the the the
theory does come true of like oh because
she had a child uh some of it was able
to be passed on and and so I I
appreciate that concept there was just
something I felt like very like they
have the two the two-handed side of
right
where you the the thing about letting go
that specifically there that one section
yeah with when they do let go of the
energy that one that one like one minute
part not even a minute that's probably
part of my uh like back my back and
forth is about it is it felt a little
too simplistic to me while I get the
idea at least is what it seems to be
about again be more Curious for women
and trans people to tell me more than I
would you know but it seemed like it
was like it was mly about women in that
moment not even so much about being
trans when because she says something a
a male doctor wouldn't understand and
yeah male presenting doctor yes yeah
yeah and there's so words right so yeah
they say they say letting go and it just
seems so it it just seemed too simple
after everything of the buildup of
that I like the idea of like commenting
on you know the fact that women
definitely have to like go even as a guy
can be like yeah I know women have to
let go a lot more than men do yeah
absolutely forces that I could see that
from an observant point of view like
yeah sure no doubt uh but in terms of
just like plot that's where I focused on
is it's seemed like a little too quick
to me on what happened there um this was
like 42 45 minutes right this this is
like 50 something minutes not not like a
full hour and change though no no it's I
feel like this is this is kind of a
classic Doctor Who thing where you you
sometimes will come to an episode where
you're like I like the idea of this
resolution I wish there was maybe a
little more time like you know there's
so much else going on there's a lot of
Madness there's a lot of reuniting and
and honoring the past and and whatnot
and uh yeah like this sequence maybe
could have been a little more breathable
so that it doesn't feel so bre easy and
it's also not liable to like Rush past
you in a sense um cuz uh definitely cuz
yeah it is it does kind of happen
rapidly and I like the principle of the
idea that it's an an emotional thing
that solves the problem it's not like oh
we need to you know find some machine or
source of energy and you know like
radiate it you know like whatever you
know mumbo jumbo they might have come up
with from a Sci-Fi
perspective wibbly wobbly W timy Wy yeah
H jinkx in order to fix this I like that
it's a self-empowered thing and I even
like the device of like when Donna's
dror energy when when he recites all the
you know um trigger words and you know
her energy is Unleashed and that
activates the energy in row like I
thought that was a smart instance of
like oh yeah that's a that's a clever
plot device that also it makes sense to
me I like the whole thing with the
binary and non-binary as well sense yeah
we are binary you are you know a woman
doctor imbued I am a doctor you know
naturally and now we've kind of you know
Amalgamated into Rose who chose her own
name and all that stuff and that's part
of the peripheral magic so yeah it's
like for me I just think that finale
scene it's like weird part of me is like
well because it's kind of brief it
doesn't Bel labor the point and then I
imagine cause that many more people to
be like oh my God woke but at the same
time just as a dramatic beat I would
have maybe just felt a little bit less
like I need to go back and look at that
again if they had let it breathe or
something which again is just a kind of
it's one of those things about Doctor
Who it's not like you just 100% give it
a pass but it is like one of those
Charming ear marks of like yeah
sometimes the wrap up is a little quick
you know yeah yeah but I mean the jovial
Spirit of it all it it doesn't it's not
going to undo the grandiose experience
of this special you know and there's a
lot of pressure on a special you know
and there's there's probably the other
pressure of the fact that you're
bringing back tenant uh you're you're
bringing back Tate as well yeah and
Russell T Davies is returning like
there's a lot happening here it is it is
a special it's a 60th
anniversary and I wouldn't put all the
Laurels in this one episode though
because they're doing several specials
and I've heard the next one is all I
heard is David Tenant described it I
think it was him as as Russell T Davies
Unleashed yeah Okay cool so I'm excited
for whatever that means cool yeah well I
think for the first episode of the
special that this was a pretty great one
like I I love the way it was shot it it
felt very vibrant throughout it is the
the chemistry the energy and the pacing
after coming off of the Whitaker season
who did that chip chibnall yes chibs
chibs um which often had this like
dreary mood to seemed like it wanted to
be the gritty reboot version yeah yeah
yeah yeah and uh to to come back to and
while they had some episodes that were a
little more lively to go back to this
flare for it uh was refreshing it felt
like New Classic yeah yeah at the same
time it it felt classic but it didn't
just feel like they're doing what they
did before it still felt like they're
advancing and doing some something new
and that I can't quite put my finger on
but there is something that feels I
guess refined about it like Russell C
Davis has had some time away and I like
that they embrace the age uh with
everything like going with a with an
older Donna and having a like she's aged
yeah she barely looks like she's same
same thing with tenant man yeah he looks
good uh tenant looks great and just to
see them like slip back into these roles
so seamlessly to the point where
yeah there's there's nothing about it
just felt stiff like they just they they
it's like I feel like we we haven't like
it's it's what's odd about it I'll tell
you what's really odd about it is you
have tenet then you have uh three more
doctors after tenet and then you're back
to tenet and you kind of forget about
those other like it just feels like pick
it up with even though this is 14 and
not 10 yeah yeah exactly yeah like it is
car which is another good choice I think
it is carrying that his it is carrying
that history but tenant is
still he's still he's doing something
different again this is like reaction so
I'm kind of processing it in a moment
like he because he has like the natural
tenet whimsies that you would expect and
the kind of lively energy that you would
expect in the the animated side of him I
guess well when he was tenth he was
darker he does seem a bit grizzled at
the like he we just talked about how
good he looks but he does look and feel
a little bit more like I don't know when
he was 10th he was a much darker
portrayal yeah yeah but I think there's
there's further darkness in like a
Capaldi even and there's a different
kind of angst in some of the darker
aspects of like Whitaker well Smith
especially and yeah they they all have
like a unique approach to the darkness
but I get what you mean it's like he's
he seems very classically tenant but
also appropriately at this again
appropriately the next one and not a
reverting to the old one there something
about even though you know there's
always a jumble of like oh how much do
they remember from their previous
Incarnation and all that stuff but but
yeah it still felt informed by the
recent events even if they're not overt
I would say even like I mean he got
along with Matt Smith great like I I
watched a lot of I watched a lot of
those interviews he's done with Matt
Smith sure um those convention
interviews there's a really funny with
them on Graham Norton and that's got to
be a blast Graham Norton should play a
doctor and I believe Tennant was the
first one to learn about Whitaker
because they were friends oh yeah
because of broad Church yeah yeah so she
called them up and yeah I think I think
How The Story Goes is tennet got a call
saying like the next doctor wants to
talk to you and then it was jod Whitaker
so I feel like he has been able to not
only just have the direct experience of
working with Matt granted there was um
uh who's the one the older oh John hert
no no no no noal Capaldi yeah there was
Capaldi after Smith yeah but I think his
I don't feel like there's really the
Capaldi experience in here but I feel
the Matt Smith and I feel the Whitaker
along with tenet kind of he like the the
uh yeah that I don't know there's
something about the Capaldi doctor that
feels like especially scarred by things
and and kind of like a kudin kudin but
who's got like some
some heavy to let go yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah he feels lighter on his feet
even though he's aged he's feels lighter
on his feet here yeah absolutely and
yeah like this this definitely felt like
a sort of I like that yeah they have
this new classic feeling where you're
like oh man we are kind of hopping back
into especially after the tonal shift of
the Whitaker era we're hopping back into
something that feels appropriately
modern with some of the production
values and whatnot but yeah has the same
amount of Bounce and the same amount of
Whimsy always kind of at the periphery
um but then I think it's smart that they
didn't just go with Nostalgia and they
didn't just go with like oh hey we're
aaging ET and Gremlins and other things
we're also like again as as much debate
as there is around relevant allegories
of this Variety in popular culture I
think that's a good sign that they are
invigor ated and they are not just here
to rest on their Laurels and Feed Us
Doctor Who flavored memberberries
they're you know trying to again there's
a good amount here yeah no there are but
but I'm saying like if it was just that
and it was just like oh isn't it nice to
have tenant and and and uh uh Katherine
Tate back and isn't isn't everything
Grant like like that would have been
enough for me to enjoy it but I think
it's nice that they you know really seem
to come in with like all guns blazing
and they brought the fun guns you know
and it makes me really excited for what
this uh Trio of specials this this
Amalgamated special will be because too
I mean often times a special means
multiple doctors which this doesn't at
least at the outset seem like the point
will be aside from that you have
multiple doctors in the form at least in
this episode of rose and uh and Donna
but but yeah like seeing I think it is
an interesting inversion on the usual
special format because now we get yeah
this like little cluster of episodes
with tenant who you know like there's
heavy debate between all the fans about
who's favorite and who when but I feel
like tenant for some reason does feel
like the one where it's like you could
periodically bring this guy back and
just make it a thing and I think he
would love it and I think we would love
it you know and you can do allegory but
you could also do fun well T if I'm not
mistaken it was it was when tenet came
in where it Doctor Who skyrocketed pierc
that veil of just it's just the geek
show or some it really took hold of
the main it took hold like really took
hold the pop culture Zeitgeist you know
for the new age yeah a th% and I I I
think that's what makes tenant
specifically so special he's so many
people's first yeah yeah totally and you
know of Tate is she slips right back
into the role like I because a big part
of what makes their
companionship feel different than a lot
of other
ones I mean you had it with like Billy
and kapal I forget they actually Billy
but you had there for obvious reasons um
oh yeah but but a lot of times there's a
bit of a
romantic inkling or hint I like those
ones but I especially enjoy these ones
but this is very platonic their Dynamic
and she's willing to like tell him if
she doesn't agree and I think that is
always really fun like a like a like a
companion who will speak up and who
isn't just going to be like what do I do
just tell me what to do like those those
always create a lovely friction and espe
especially with David ten I think is is
yeah it's it's pretty Exquisite and I
like the daughter the the one who played
rose I thought she was great yeah I
thought she was great she was excellent
I wish we had a little more time with
her I wish we had a you know there's
something another thing I'm kind of
backing forth on is I I like kind of the
passive portrayal of
Shawn as this guy always up for anything
he's he's just always like sure fine
just yes anding his way through life cuz
part of the performance feels like he
went through hell
after agreeing to give away the lottery
money sure and he just sort of suckered
it up and he's just that guy now who's
always like yep fine I'm rolling with it
I'm just choosing full always nothing
matters anymore like I feel like there's
a little bit of a of a stress ball just
growing in his brain um but but there's
something that translat is so funny cuz
it it could have easily been the other
direction of who's this man why do you
want to be like they could have done
some some type of like Amy and Rory
thingy to a certain extent right um but
they didn't do that at all so there's
something that was kind of funny about
it it very Charming but and that
compliments nicely that Sharon is so
concerned and so averse to like any of
this happening um well the the mom
before has been you know kind of
a a pensive like a new a Nuance to deal
with like she was she was had that
classic like
judgmental yeah I I I nag you cuz I love
you but I'm going be overbearing about
it and they they managed to take those
qualities but convert it into protection
yeah totally and you really feel the
history on her especi yeah that was fun
that was a lot of fun I like the Meep
design uh a lot I'm not familiar I don't
know where meeps cuz Meep come from I
think I think if I think I heard that
meeps come from like an audio book or a
comic book something like that okay I
think they're some extended materials
yeah uh but I didn't know anything about
like what the personality traits are
supposed to be like if there if this is
their history or some like I don't
know anything about about what the meeps
are supposed to be sure but they had me
going like uh because I I I thought like
it was creepy to endearing I think I
said that it was like creepy to
endearing and but it but it sold me on
okay I guess it's going to be like good
yeah it really plays off of it smartly
plays off of your uh just yeah you
seeing the figures in the situation and
making a judgment yeah and using that
judgment to subvert your expectations so
yeah that whole thing about like oh
these are stun guns interesting why you
know and then these guys you know these
Soldier guys are out to kill but yeah I
thought that was a nice switch around
and a good a further compliment to the
allegory in a less obvious way where
it's like oh yeah things aren't as they
seem yeah we still haven't got I'm
assuming the boss is toy maker must be
that that seems like what it what it
would be unless they're doing some other
craziness Beyond out beyond that but I
feel like yeah toy maker is probably the
one because too you know she's making
the toys and the Meep hides among the
toy I feel like yeah it's probably
hearkening to that yeah seemed like
there were some hints at least going to
that and and you know who knows maybe
there's something to do with the toy
makers to why tenant is back in his
tenant form it's fun to speculate this
time because before we would speculate
at patreon it's like everyone already
knows I don't want to get spoiled so
let's not speculate too hard but now
yeah being in real time like it's nice
to be a part of the momentum and the
excitement that comes with the new stuff
yeah it was spoiled for us the tenant
was like uh re she regenerates in the
tenant yeah yeah you know and because I
was like impossible to avoid yeah you
know what I also enjoyed about this
really quick is I like the way they
handle old Bernard cribbons uh and they
give you a little moment for the doctor
to lament the loss of wil and then
realize that yeah they just have Himes
on off screen he's alive and well and
they're going to go visit him maybe at
some point and like I hope we don't get
some kind of AI regenerated Bernard
cribbons unless he really wanted that I
mean I I remember hearing that there're
supposed to be some scene where he pulls
up next to him in a
car I think on the Pacific palisad yes
definitely they come all the way to
America wils is riding a hot
rod and uh yeah see again starts
playing yep I'm pretty sure what happen
yeah they got Whiz Khalifa to be a
doctor to come in
andent heard that totally and they got
uh Berard crib's brother to stand in for
him you know so they can shoot the
scenes so it was it was the family
approved of it okay it's cool that wolf
lives on yeah I'm happy about that there
are a lot of ways you can handle that
and obviously if you make him alive part
of us goes I want to see him but at the
same time I'm happy he's out there well
I'm I'm realizing this so late one of
the big I mean it was like the thing
that led to his regeneration uh for
tenant tenant
regenerating um into Matt Smith was The
Showdown in the cases with wolf and then
they kind of have a mirroring effect oh
sure oh my God good call when they're in
the yeah they're split in the yeah the
chambers basically makes two of the
radiation Chambers or whatever except
yeah like slightly different
circumstances but yeah it is a good call
back to that damn that's good yeah and
that was such a heartbreaking scene like
oh God and like yeah the last time the
doctor saw him he like totally snapped
at him and and you know brought it back
around but still like it was it was a
tumultuous moment so I'm glad that you
know they get to visit cuz you feel that
in the doctor's face too when when he
thinks he's dead and he's like oh like
you you feel the guilt of some of those
you know past moments th% yeah but uh
also then the the I think that's also a
nice kind of uh but I was so in the
moment of like is she about to die here
because this seems fast yeah I didn't
think about that to right now yeah know
and that's that's a nice thing is I
think that's a sign that this is you
know got a lot of TLC on on it and they
put a lot of you know care and and
detail and richness into what they're
trying to do so even if it is a little
bit crammed here or there or certain
moments feel maybe a little quick here
or there that's Doctor Who that's Doctor
Who and there are wor way more uh way
less cohesive versions of those kinds of
Doctor Who pitfalls so like yeah here
that was great no I mean blast I think
with I think the thing with a special
more than anything else that matters is
the the um the spirit yeah as long as
the spirit feels G feels um I don't it
doesn't have to be jovial it's nice when
it is it just has to be spiritually
tuned and have its eye on the Legacy
it's trying to you know yeah you can
like logically look at some and be
like the could have breathed better and
what like I think a lot of times you
could do that but it's a special it's
like it's an Avengers movie you know
justart special yeah part of me is also
like well we see how these all feel as a
trio once they're all done you know and
it's rare when you go in I mean you
always know the doctor the doctor will
eventually regenerate into someone else
you know that but it's rare when you go
into to a a special with a doctor
knowing this is going to be very
shortlived yeah so just have fun with
the ride appreciate the precious moments
yeah exactly it'll take another
Milestone to maybe get tenant back or or
you know some kind of crossover of
doctors yeah so like this doesn't happen
all the time obviously no it doesn't and
so just have fun um because it's going
to be shortlived and we know it is and I
think that in a way it's yeah it'll make
these feel precious but I think it'll
also make for an interesting transition
into um I think it's I think it's shuti
gwa uh the the new doctor after three
episodes of a classic I think will be an
interesting transition point
uh no it's um idba Ida yeah my bad it's
Denzel Washington I think we can have a
lot of sincere commentary about trans
rights of course and being supportive
but but it's definitely Samuel L Jackson
if we can make a couple of satirical
racist CHS sure sure sure oh yeah yeah
yeah then cuz we're in a post-racism
world now that all the time yeah it
doesn't exist anymore yeah now you can't
joke about identities
unless they're of like old news
like race mhm then you can go Hog Wild
yeah um but no I loved it I I had a
great time I I had a great time and I
can't wait to see the rest very happy
eating good today leaves me wanting more
absolute cuts to credits abruptly the
way you expected yep oh we're back it's
over you know and then we'll whatever
whatever we left off on we'll figure
that out beginning of the next episode
and then we'll move into the next
adventure maybe NPH will show up all
righty guys what did you think about
this special leave your thoughts down
below be sure to subscribe like this
video follow us on
patreon and hey let's send this with
a Chase Gardner chase this just seems
like a fitting doctor to shout you out
on because tennet loves to be on foot
he's known to be one of the most um uh
cardiovascular driven doctor
out there constantly running around
aerobically inclined doctor and then
Gardener because I I that just when I
hear that I just feel like Serene at
ease yeah he's a cultivator he helps
things grow and he helps you know Aid in
a peaceful sort of natural holistic way
that's the way I feel right now or both
of these emotions so I thought shouting
you out just kind of made the most sense
chased Into The Gardens of our souls mhm
yeah and dude you've been a part of our
page getting shout outs for the longest
time you have been unbelievably loyal to
us I need you to go the extra mile now
yes it's time to step it up if there's
any other patreon Pages you pledge to
I'm going to ask for your devoted
Allegiance here I don't care if they
have nothing to do with us I don't care
if you pledge less I don't care if you
only pledge a dollar you're going to
have to sever ties with them now yeah
unpledged from everyone else you're
going to have to convert those pledges
into a higher pledge a mono pledge a
real rejects come on man we rendering
2024 you've been here for a very long
time can't grow a garden without you
know pledges you got to go to the next
step here buddy yeah and it's up to you
it's all on your back you got to put the
whole patreon on your back you got to
support us through the the future and
Beyond because now that we're not doing
Doctor Who exclusively over there take a
hit uh oh yeah now people are going to
realize they can just get Doctor Who
anywhere on the YouTubes or wherever
else unless you want to sync up with
your own copy and enjoy the full length
reaction experience which is only
available at patreon which you know Max
version often
conflicted oh good you know how that
goes oh excellent HBO I wonder if the
Disney Plus One will conflict with the
PVC version oh because pal because pal
is a different frame right oh
interesting yeah we'll see how it goes
25 FPS maybe we should just shoot all
Doctor Who in 25 FPS I don't never watch
on Disney plus we'll see how it goes all
righty guys well Chase carner thanks for
Vi here man see you
[Music]
well